2. Ngoài Hà Mịt Tư tháng 6, phòng cảnh sát kinh tế, công an tỉnh đồng này cho biết đang tức tục mở giộn điều tra,
làm só hình vì sản xuất, buông bản phân bóng giả tại công ty chế giảm hiểu hạn thương mại,
dịch vụ phát tiến chiến có chú sở tại sát hương lột, hình thông nhất, tỉnh đồng này.
Chứ đó, lực lượng chức năng gồm, phòng cảnh sát kinh tế, công an tỉnh đồng này,
công an sát hương lột và chi cục quả lĩ thiệt chương đồng này đã tiến hành kìm tra đồ xuất cơ sở chiến,
só là săng đình, 3.5 tuổi, quý bình chế, làm sản đông. Quả kìm tra,
phát hiện công ty có giấu hiểu sản xuất, buông bản hàng giả là phân bóng cùng nhiều sản phẩm sự dụng trong đông nghiệp.
Tại hiện chương, nhà dựng dộ khoảng 1 yên mết đang có bún công nhân hoạt động sản xuất.
Lực lượng chức năng tù giữa hơn sau tấn hàng hóa thành phẩm,
mùi bà về bà tấn quyền liệu, cùng các mấy móc phục vụ sản xuất nhiều mấy mại bảo, mấy em nhìn,
bước đầu, là săng đình khai nhận công ty hoạt động không phép từ tháng 1 năm 2020,
người liệu được nhập tự chung quốc và một số cơ sở trong nước,
bà bị mô trên mạng xả hội, sau đó phát chộ đong coi bán gia các tình đậu bằng xong cử làm.
Huyến cuộc việc đang được tiếp tục điều tra, sử lý theo quý định.